.
WE APPRECIATE IT VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
THE OTHER BIG STORY WE ARE
FOLLOWING THIS AFTERNOON, THE
HOUSE INVESTIGATING JANUARY
6TH.
IN LESS THAN 24 HOURS THE PANEL
IS EXPECTED TO MAKE CRIMINAL
REFERRALS TO THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT, RECOMMENDING THE
PROSECUTION FORMER PRESIDENT
DONALD TRUMP.
THE REFERRALS ARE EXPECTED TO
INCLUDE CHARGES OF INSURRECTION,
OBSTRUCTION OF AN OFFICIAL
PROCEEDING, AND CONSPIRACY TO
DEFRAUD THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
IT WILL BE THE CULMINATION OF
ALMOST A YEAR AND A HALF OF
INVESTIGATIONS INTO THE FORMER
PRESIDENT, HIS ALLIES, AND THE
ATTEMPT TO OVERTURN THE 2020
ELECTION.
>> AS A FORMER PROSECUTOR, I
THINK THERE IS SUFFICIENT
EVIDENCE TO CHARGE THE
PRESIDENT.
>> TO GET A CONVICTION, THOUGH?
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT HAS, WHAT IN
THE PUBLIC RECORD.
IT SEEMS PRETTY PLAIN TO ME.
THIS IS SOMEONE WHO IN MULTIPLE
WAYS TRYING TO PRESSURE STATE
OFFICIALS TO FIND VOTES THAT
DIDN'T EXIST, THIS IS SOMEONE
WHO TRIED TO INTERFERE WITH A
JOINT SESSION, EVEN INCITING A
MOB TO ATTACK THE CAPITOL.
IF THAT'S NOT CRIMINAL, THEN I
DON'T KNOW WHAT IS.
>> JOINING ME NOW, ONE OF THE
OFFICERS WHO DEFENDED THE
CAPITOL ON JANUARY 6TH, LAW
ENFORCEMENT ANALYST AND FORMER
D.C. METROPOLITAN POLICE
OFFICER, MICHAEL PINON.
HE'S THE AUTHOR OF THE BOOK,
HOLD THE LINE.
THE INSURRECTION AND ONE COPS
BATTLE FOR AMERICA'S SOUL.
MIKE, THANKS AGAIN FOR BEING
WITH US.
AS ALWAYS, WE APPRECIATE IT.
WE ARE AT THE END OF A 17 MONTH
CONGRESSIONAL INVESTIGATION
INTO EVERYTHING THAT HAPPENED
THAT DAY.
YOU AND I HAVE TALKED ABOUT
THIS SEVERAL TIMES.
I KNOW YOU'VE BEEN PESSIMISTIC
ABOUT ANY KIND OF PROSPECT OF
TRUMP BEING BROUGHT UP ON
CHARGES, ULTIMATELY, FOR HIS
ROLE IN WHAT HAPPENED ON
JANUARY 6TH.
DOES THE COMMITTEE OFFERING UP
THESE CRIMINAL REFERRALS TO THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT, DO YOU
THINK IT MOVES US IN THAT
DIRECTION OF SEEING CHARGES,
REAL CRIMINAL CHARGES, A
PROSECUTION BROUGHT AGAINST THE
FORMER PRESIDENT?
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> I MEAN, I DON'T KNOW IF THIS
IS GOING TO HAVE ANY INFLUENCE
ON THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
OBVIOUSLY, AT THAT EXECUTIVE
LEVEL OF GOVERNMENT AGENCIES,
POLITICS DOES PLAY A PART IN
THEIR DECISION-MAKING, DESPITE
THEM SAYING IT DOES NOT.
I THINK IT IS APPROPRIATE THAT
THIS IS THE WAY THE SELECT
COMMITTEE CONCLUDES THE 17
MONTH INVESTIGATION.
ALTHOUGH FOR ME, I DON'T NEED A
PIECE OF PAPER REFERRING
CRIMINAL CHARGES FOR
INDIVIDUALS THAT WERE THE
TARGET OF THAT INVESTIGATION.
THE INVESTIGATION, AND THE
EVIDENCE THAT IT TURNED UP IN
AND OF ITSELF, TO ME, IS THE
CRIMINAL REFERRAL.
>> AND AS WE JUST MENTIONED,
THE COMMITTEE IS EXPECTED TO
URGE THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
TO PROSECUTE TRUMP ON THREE
CHARGES, INCLUDING INSURRECTION.
THE REFERRAL OF CRIMINAL
CHARGES, THE PRESIDENT WILL BE
A MOMENT IN AMERICAN HISTORY.
ICING WILL CLOSE OUT THE DAY
TOMORROW WITH THAT HEADLINE, IN
EVERY NEWSPAPER ACROSS THE
COUNTRY, ON EVERY TELEVISION
NETWORK ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
WILL THAT FEEL LIKE ANY MEASURE
OF JUSTICE FOR YOU?
>> FOR ME, PERSONALLY, NO.
THERE'S A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT I
HAVE SPOKEN TO, SPECIFICALLY IN
WASHINGTON, THAT ARE LIKE, WELL,
HE WAS TWICE IMPEACHED.
THAT'S A BIG DEAL.
WELL, I THINK FOR THE AVERAGE
AMERICAN, THAT DOESN'T MEAN
ANYTHING.
THERE WERE NO CONSEQUENCES AS A
RESULT OF THAT.
AND QUITE FRANKLY, I DON'T
BELIEVE POLITICAL
ACCOUNTABILITY IS REAL
ACCOUNTABILITY.
THIS IS A PERSON WHO, THERE IS
A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
EVIDENCE THAT HAS BEEN TURNED
UP THAT HE COMMITTED CRIMINAL
ACTS, AS WELL AS MANY OF HIS
ALLIES.
SOME OF WHOM ARE STILL IN POWER
TODAY.
AND SO I THINK THAT THE ONLY
ACCOUNTABILITY IS CRIMINAL
ACCOUNTABILITY.
DONALD TRUMP SHOULD BE INDICTED,
AS SHOULD HIS COCONSPIRATORS
AND ALLIES THAT HAVE SUPPORTED
THE CRIMES THAT HE COMMITTED,
AND HE COMMITTED CRIMES
THEMSELVES.
THOSE INDIVIDUALS SHOULD BE PUT
ON TRIAL FOR AMERICA, AND AS
I'VE SAID BEFORE, WE SHOULD
ACCEPT THE RESULTS OF THAT
TRIAL, EVEN IF THEY ARE IN FACT
A CONVICTION, WHICH LEADS
DONALD TRUMP TO SERVE TIME IN
PRISON.
>> AND WHAT WOULD THAT CHARGE
BE?
WHAT SHOULD BE INDICTED ON, DO
YOU THINK?
>> OBVIOUSLY, I BELIEVE HE IS
GUILTY OF OBSTRUCTION, AND I DO
BELIEVE THAT HE, ALONG WITH
MEMBERS OF HIS ADMINISTRATION
AND HIS ALLIES NOT ENGAGED IN
EFFORTS TO DEFRAUD THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
BY LYING ABOUT THE RESULTS OF
THE 2020 ELECTION, WHICH WAS
PROVEN TO HAVE BEEN FREE AND
FAIR, AND THAT AS A RESULT OF
THOSE LIES, AND THE PRESSURE
CAMPAIGN THAT HE AND HIS ALLIES
ENGAGED IN, THAT WE SAW THE
VIOLENCE THAT PLAYED OUT ON
JANUARY 6TH AT UNITED'S
CAPITAL.
>> THE COMMITTEE IS ALSO
CONSIDERING WHETHER TO HOLD
REPUBLICAN LAWMAKERS
ACCOUNTABLE FOR DEFYING THEIR
SUBPOENAS DURING THE
INVESTIGATION.
MIKE, AS YOU SAW THROUGHOUT THE
INVESTIGATION, UP ON CAPITOL
HILL, SEVERAL MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS WERE ABLE TO THUMB
THEIR NOSE AT THE COMMITTEE AND
NOT PARTICIPATE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK SHOULD HAPPEN
THERE?
>> I MEAN, LISTEN, I WAS A COP
FOR 20 YEARS.
AND IF YOU DEFIED A SUBPOENA,
YOU WERE ARRESTED.
THAT'S IT.
I KNOW THAT THERE HAS BEEN TALK
ABOUT --
THERE MAY NOT BE ANY OFFICIAL
MECHANISM TO DO SO, OTHER THAN
I GUESS THE UNITED STATES
POLICE, OR MAYBE IT'S THE HOUSE
AND SENATE SERGEANT AT ARMS.
BUT LISTEN, THEY NEED TO --
IF YOU ARE GOING TO RESTORE THE
CREDIBILITY OF CONGRESS IN
LEADING THESE KINDS OF
INVESTIGATIONS, PEOPLE THAT
DEFY SUBPOENAS SHOULD BE
ARRESTED.
MEMBER OF THE JANUARY SIXZINGERY
COMMITTEE.
HE IS LEAVING CONGRESS AND IN
HIS FAREWELL SPEECH ON THE
FLOOR, HE REFLECTED ON THE COST
THAT CAME WITH PURSUING THE
TRUTH.
LET'S LISTEN TO THAT.
>> HAD I KNOW THAT STANDING UP
FOR TRUTH WOULD COST ME MY JOB,
FRIENDSHIPS, AND EVEN MY
PERSONAL SECURITY I WOULD --
WITHOUT HESITATION, DO IT ALL
OVER AGAIN.
>> I CAN REST EASY AT NIGHT,
KNOWING THAT I FULFILLED MY ALL
OATH TO THE OFFICE.
I KNOW MANY IN THIS INSTITUTION
CANNOT DO THE SAME.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT THAT,
MIKE?
>> I SUPPOSE YOU PROBABLY CAN
RELATE TO WHAT HE JUST SAID
THERE.
>> OH, ABSOLUTELY.
ADAM IS ONE OF THE FEW MEMBERS
OF CONGRESS THAT I HAVE
CONSIDERABLE CONSIDERABLE
AMOUNT OF RESPECT FOR AND ALSO
THE PRIVILEGE TO CALL A
PERSONAL FRIEND OF MINE.
THERE ARE A LOT OF PARALLELS
BETWEEN HIS EXPERIENCES AND MY
EXPERIENCE, ESPECIALLY WHEN IT
COMES TO THE AMOUNT OF THREATS
THAT HAVE BEEN LEVELED AGAINST
OUR FAMILIES.
THAT BEING SAID, I KIND OF
DEVELOPED THIS SAYING WHEN I
SPEAK TO PEOPLE THAT THE TRUTH
WILL SET YOU FREE FROM IN
EMPLOYMENT.
UNFORTUNATELY, THAT SEEMS TO BE
THE WAY OF THE WORLD.
AT LEAST IN REGARDS TO HERE IN
AMERICA, AT THIS POINT IN TIME.
>> BUT YOU AND OTHER OFFICERS
WERE AWARDED THE CONGRESSIONAL
GOLD MEDAL FOR YOUR RESPONSE TO
THE RIOT, TO THE INSURRECTION.
HAVE YOU HAD SOME TIME TO
REFLECT ON THAT MOMENT?
>> I'M --
I MEAN, IN A WAY, I GUESS.
I DON'T WANT TO TAKE AWAY FROM
THE EXPERIENCE THAT THESE OTHER
OFFICERS THAT HAD THAT.
MANY OF WHOM, IT WAS THE FIRST
THAT THEY WERE RECOGNIZED FOR
WHAT THEY DID ON JANUARY 6TH,
WHICH WAS NOTHING SHORT OF
INCREDIBLY COURAGEOUS AND
SELFLESS.
AND FORTUNATELY, I GOT TO SEE
HOW THE SAUSAGE IS MADE IN
REGARDS TO THAT AWARDS SO IT
LOST A LOT OF ITS SIGNIFICANCE
AND MEANING FOR ME PERSONALLY.
ALSO, ALL TIMIDLY, I PAID A
HIGH PRICE TO ADVOCATE --
ADVOCATING FOR ACKNOWLEDGMENT
FOR ALL OF THOSE OTHER OFFICERS
THAT I SAW FIGHT SO BRAVELY ON
JANUARY 6TH.
>> MIKE, THERE ARE SO MANY
AMERICANS AROUND THE COUNTRY SO
THANK HERE FOR WHAT YOU DID ON
THAT DAY, AND REST OF THE
OFFICERS, AS YOU MENTIONED WHO
DEFENDED THE CAPITOL ON JANUARY
6TH.